[Music]
brought to you by hulu time to have
great original shows and movies time to
have hulu
hey what's up party people welcome back
from the long weekend we are here to
talk all things clueless in the honest
trailer commentaries for the film of the
same name uh we're gonna watch the
trailer together we're going to talk
about our thoughts and cut jokes from
the movies we'll show those at the end
we'll talk to uh you guys about
questions you may have so keep those
coming in the chat and then we'll tease
you with next week's on his trailer we
were just
oh god silence your phones people this
is
have some respect for the cinema
danielle
which this is um we were talking uh
let's just talk about clueless um
because we were talking about a
different film that we're doing next
week but which i want to keep talking
about but fine we'll talk about clueless
because it's great who doesn't like
clueless do any of you not like clueless
it's one of my favorite movies it's like
literally when i i have a list of good
bad movies and then just good movies
that i like and this is on the like top
five of good movies that i like yeah i
think that this is always a treat to go
back and watch um
and it only gets better with age uh it
feels like a uh a period piece like like
stranger things is making fun of the 90s
with the amount of 90s stuff that they
put in there but no this is the real
deal this is real 1995.
well this was
trying to be very like
you know like let's put everything in
that kids like yeah you know a little
bit
and kids like the mighty mighty boss
tones uh what do you wow apparently
what do you think about the this film on
i was amazed at how quickly it like flew
by like it's so light on its feet it's
like you
even compared to good
you know like sort of coming of age high
school comedies from from later i feel
like this has got to be one of the the
fastest pace like you're in and you're
out it just feels like there's no down
time it's not like a lot of those
comedies where okay we've gotten through
the funny stuff now we've got to hit
pause and like work out all the
relationships like it's all just one
package it's super tight and yeah just
it's it's very very entertaining
yeah like one thing after another
there's you're never waiting for the
next beat pickeresque i'd say and and
that kind of mirrors the the novel it
was based on and and novels back but
they weren't they all released like
chapter by chapter segment by segment
and then people i don't i don't jane
austen not most serialized like that i
don't know if they were maybe i'm gonna
pretend they were because it makes me
sound [ __ ] i know like
famously
dickens was famous famously serialized
but i'm not i'm not sure you could tell
me anything i was a theater major tell
me it's one of those words
it might have also been like you know
like it was it was multi-part but it was
published in like four installments and
then collected like that sometimes
happened too if it wasn't like every
month you got a chapter i don't know
i will say that emma it's a
yeah it updates remarkably well to to
the 90s like and and this is the the
best um
analogy for i guess like the landed
british aristocracy is the is the dumb
clueless people who live in a bubble in
beverly hills i think it actually works
super well um so i think we should just
watch the trailer we got more to say so
let's uh let's pause and go as we see
let's roll it first
three volumes by the way emma was first
published hey there you go
nice
so smart about both from the dictated
that brought you the sincerity of grunge
the slacking of generation x and the
dursting of fred comes another relic of
a bygone era
a mid-budget studio comedy
clueless
gotta miss those welcome comments
okay west la all right like five blocks
of l.a not a taco inside and meet cher a
rich girl with a two dollar brain full
of ten dollar words i've tried
everything to convince him of my
scholastic aptitude but i was brutally
rebuffed chill as if you through the
world of 90s teen culture
as seen through the eyes of a spoiled
rich girl
as seen through the eyes of a much older
screenwriter i don't want to be a
traitor to my generation and all but i
don't get how guys dress today okay
literal boomer
watches share matures from a plastic
doll who squeaks when she doesn't get
her way
oh
all right let's pause uh oh there'll be
more share stuff but
do you guys like cher as a character and
why or do you not and why are you on
that do you ride that edge i do i find
her it's one of those things where it's
like oh like i just want to pat her on
the head like oh
you you could have been smart and you
couldn't like because she shows moments
where she's very compassionate and she
shows moments where she actually kind of
gets things that are happening in the
world but she was raised in this bubble
where it's like she just doesn't know
and so like uh obviously she's a pro a
product of extreme privilege but i also
just like i don't know i'm older now i
have empathy i just want to pat her on
the head and be like let me teach you
things you know
yeah yeah i mean and the movie is like
the movie is kind of skewering her
perspective at the same time um
she is just so she comes across so
innocent like a little bunny you want a
pet and say they're there it's okay you
tried
i was sort of thinking i was thinking a
little bit about white lotus when i was
watching this and i know that's a con
like in the novel emma i feel like she's
allowed to make more of a like she arcs
like by the end she's sort of realized
she not only
recognizes that she loves mr nightly you
know aka paul rudd in this like
she comes to that realization but in the
novel she also sort of realizes like oh
i've been horrible to these people and i
need to like change my perspective on
the world and cher doesn't really she
realizes that she loves paul rub but she
doesn't really change her view but i
feel like that's kind of part of the
satire it sort of works in the movie
like she wouldn't have a total epiphany
she would just realize like what's going
on in this limited situation and how to
like fix it um so i yeah i feel like
that kind of works like she's not
likable but you understand who she is
and and her world view and how she fits
in and i think it's that balance of
satire where we like her but not so much
that we can't still make fun of her i
will say i do think she has more of an
arc um it's just a weird kind of
zigzaggy arc because she does start with
her
like it starts with her being very
selfish and she puts together those two
teachers because she wants to get her
grades together and then she meets ty
and granted it's not great to suddenly
be like who you are as trash and i'm
gonna make you not trash um but it does
represent her being like i want to do
something for someone else so there is
like a even though like that person
winds up like totally like she creates a
monster who then unmonsters herself
um
so she imagined dragons monsters now in
my head and so she
um sorry don't want to get stupid but so
she um it does wind up
being a little but it's also like it's
such a small it's like a it's not a
these it's like a yeah i would say that
it's it's like a it's a narrow wobble of
an arc and she doesn't need to i think
that there's plenty of stories she's
like a forest gumpy and character like a
chauncey gardener or superman even where
like they don't change they kind of like
inspire the people around them to change
because i think she ends the movie as
about as clueless as she starts like his
mo the pismo beach disaster
i understand she's a little less
judgmental like in the beginning she's
like those are the burnouts we don't
hang out with them like by the end it's
got that mean girls thing if she's sort
of recognized the humanity even in
people she wouldn't have before i i get
that it's there i just feel like they
amy hecker for the purposes of comedy
allows her to be kind of a crummy person
right up until the end of the movie uh
and i i i don't i didn't mind that
watching it i feel like that kind of
well it's set in beverly hills about
these extremely privileged people it
would take more than one life experience
to knock her out of this
loop and i feel like that it works for
the movie that we're watching yeah it's
on purpose which is like i think like
that's like the thing where people get
like oh well i don't like the characters
or the movies bad like sometimes it's on
purpose you're not supposed to like
sometimes writing is good
this is a direct yeah like send up of
these people like we're not just
supposed to love them we're also
supposed to kind of judge them and and
uh you know like look at how skewed
their world view is by where they live
and the circumstances in which they've
grown up but it works really well at
that without making it mean i mean i
think that's the the knife's edge that
she's walking with this whole movie is
that we're not condemning these people
in a hateful way we like them it's just
it's it's doing both here here all right
well said let's keep watching
to a thoughtful woman who realizes the
error of her ways eventually ty is my
pal i don't begrudge her boyfriend i
really oh i wonder if they have that my
size
sorta lucy you know i don't speak
mexican
i'm not a mexican okay she doesn't
realize the error of her ways but she
does realize which boy she has a crush
on i love josh
it's a start
throw on your best plaid miniskirt and
join the popular click with cher's
bestie dion whose job is reacting to
stuff
stop
[Music]
i'm already seeing in the comments a lot
of people doing a a a great job pitching
the joke um from reaction face to
reactionary and bravo i wish i thought
of that first
so i love that yeah keep it coming all
right anyways keep going which
considering stacy dash is some whole
deal the fewer chances to speak the
better i guess a lot of people in the
transgender community would then say
it is who i am okay then go go to the
bushes i don't know what to tell you
britney murphy is ty a transfer student
from the school of hard dogs
but when cher transforms her into a
fellow hot mean girl you're a virgin who
can't drive it'll take all of eight
minutes before she apologizes and the
main conflict is diffused i'm so sorry
ty oh [ __ ] i'm really sorry there's
really not much of a part of this
uh embraces skater raper culture i
totally have that shirt yeah yeah i just
missed that um but like my older brother
and cousins definitely had like
short pants that were so baggy that
they'd wear suspenders under their
shirts to hold them up because like
belts wouldn't do the trick well and
look there were pants for women
i'm aging myself but there were pants
for women that used to have a crotch
pocket because that's where you could
put your drugs because they wouldn't pat
you up there
crouch pocket yeah
it really is eight minutes from conflict
to conflict over in the movie right yeah
important to point out uh i didn't mind
it i i think not all movies need uh uh
like one overarching thing look at chef
that's just about like a dude in a truck
cooking food well i mean we we sort of
bring up the mean girls comparison i
like mean girls as well but that's an
example of how i think the plot kind of
forces them towards the end like they do
have to kind of like okay we'll put the
put the comedy over here and now we're
gonna like
here's the message and here's what
you're getting out of this and clueless
does not ever make that transition i
mean
pulls that up very well but mean girls
nails it but i think that most comedies
run into a lot of trouble in the third
act when they're like put the comedy
over here come on like turn the chair
around turn your head backwards
about you know community yeah
all right
plot to this flick it's mostly just kids
not realizing who likes them great then
ty you'll go with summer and cherry
you'll come with me
actually you could take will shirt to
cannon and that turns into benedict well
because of girls the californians
i don't know
do you see how he's falling in love with
me i mean look how he ignores every
other girl what am i gonna do with that
i don't want it
if high schoolers were really this
clueless we'd have ways
yeah looking back on a christian this
time
he like he stepped into a time tunnel
and got like spit out in 1995.
i'm worried about him
he's using he is using slang that like
literally even with context his
classmates would not be picking up like
they're they all just understand what
he's saying it's like a foreign language
half the time also i watching this as an
adult
my queer dar is just bing bing
and as an adult i'm like oh no that dude
is gay
right but like was that a was that an
affectation in the 90s it's like if
you're if you're gay you talk like uh
like someone from the 1930s well and
that's what i like about his character
so much is that it's combining this
thing which is like that was in like
those like swing kids those
ring-a-ding-ding kids those want to be
ratchet yeah that was it was there was
gave him more of a character yeah there
definitely was that beatnik hipster 50
60s way like that was the thing in the
90s for sure i think he's an extreme
version like i don't think i ever heard
anybody ask somebody where the clambake
was or if they could have a fin to go
get a beer like that seems pretty far
like you're going i think further back
into the arcane phrases than most teens
would go but
there definitely was the like greaser
beatnik
like bring back these 50 subcultures
things in the 90s uh
yeah and i do i will say as someone who
uh has said 23 skidoo and has now turned
it into and i say skadooch all the time
um i totally say skadooch all the time
like a lot some of that did wind up
making its way into
um at least like west coast culture um
and again i think that's another thing
where it's like he could only have that
affectation because he has the money um
yeah yeah
um if they remake clueless what what uh
uh what era is he um pulling from
oh my gosh
or do they just make him a furry or
something
i think it's the same i think you go
right back to the same i think he's like
just 30s 40 slang still
like flipping flipping a coin you know
he's like
he's got like a fedora you know yeah one
of the one of the defining things
around yeah our current era is that like
everything is now retro and we're not
really being um
selective about it used to be like there
would be a certain era that would be
really in at a certain time now we just
do everything it's just a hodgepodge
yeah yeah because right like what would
he be like he'd be like well there are
plenty of people who are still into that
kind of you know look but that you know
like every era has people who are into
that era now
it's a free-for-all sorry i put that uh
that bad mojo into the universe of
remaking clueless but it'll happen i
mean i guess they keep making emma but
yeah we just got an ammo remake uh last
year yeah all right let's keep playing
don't forget to check out all the boys
like donald faison who used movie magic
to not look like a total ugo he had fake
braces famously in clueless yes because
they were trying to hide my small teeth
they shaved my head in clueless because
my hairline was receding at 18. travis
it's nice to see people in in movies
from let's say the late 90s and before
who actually had like regular human
sized teeth like everybody now has a
complete mouth full of chiclets i find
wow call me out spencer
i didn't well if you got it done it was
very very uh subtle and i didn't notice
but i broke my front teeth so i had to
get new ones oh okay i was a party
monster i wouldn't be able to resist the
temptation to do at least one gold tooth
but that's just me that's just me
i just want to be able to just go like
go like two sizes too big and have the
matt dylan from something about mary
can i do
if you could tell like a weird story
yeah please oh uh so when i got again i
broke these teeth um because i was a
party monster and um i just did and when
i went to go get them done they made
them too long and the dentist was like
this these are trendy teeth now these
are the teeth everyone's doing these
like really long bunny teeth and i was
like i've never heard of trendy too that
is one teeth that looks like my teeth
right like this
yeah and i looked over and it was this
dentist where it was her and her two
daughters both works this place and i
looked over into a zoo like
like they all had bunny teeth
they were trying to give me their teeth
that's a very mild human centipede
situation where she's just
everybody's elongating their ears
we're putting these cottontails above
the ass crack of all of our clients
all right let's keep playing
travis the only guy to go to rehab for
pot see i joined this club and and yeah
the always sensual wall is sean
and of course josh played by a
time-traveling paul rudd he shares love
interest who also happens to be her
ex-step-brother which the movie
desperately wants to make okay he's your
step-brother you are hardly even married
to his mother and that was five years
ago peter's not your dad josh you are
not my brother uh-huh it's only been
your time
this is just the this rewatch the thing
that really clicked for me was not that
it's uh exceptionally creepy that they
uh her dad used to be married to his mom
five years ago what's creepy is that
he's an older man dating a 16 year old
and he looks like he didn't
yeah uh it was complicated math because
in the beginning of the movie she's 15.
and he is in college so he's like 18 19.
um and then she does turn 16 during the
course of the movie but it's still like
i don't know man
uh i remember being in college and i
still thought that 16 year olds weren't
people oh just like if you were freshman
in college you like went back to visit
your high school campus that's not cool
yeah
it's that she's not even a senior like
that i feel like if she was a senior
and he was in college you'd be like all
right but after this school year she's
going to go to college it will just be
to college we only have a few months of
weirdness left no he's going to go
back for prom
right
college students but no if even if she's
a junior in the clueless year that's a
full school year now like he's got to go
yeah homecoming and prom and it's a bad
it's a bad scene you don't want to love
you
bad luck no not cool not cool red
anyways especially like what happens if
he brings her around and it's you know
share from clueless also like he's never
gonna live that down
all right keep playing
help josh i'm caught in the washing
machine
but i wish i didn't get that right then
dating a 16 year old girl and he looks
like paul ryde what happened dude did
every girl on campus see halloween six
[Music]
we might get marky mark to plant a
celebrity tree in an adaptation of a
jane austen novel but it skips most of
the social commentary cuts half the
characters and reworks a 500 page
narrative about class into a bubblegum
raw that turned all your assigned
reading into hollywood gold i'm not
saying julia styles owes alicia
silverstone a check but she owes alicia
silverstone a check
so get ready for a movie that captures
all the major trends of its decade like
box office hits about big old dummies
movies where a band with the horn
section randomly shows up and films
about an attractive actress pretending
to be an ugly duckling until they get a
makeover guys she's got glasses and a
ponytail ah look at that she's got paint
on her over
that's that's the perfect takedown of
that whole truck they really nailed it
that is the one parody movie that i well
i actually haven't watched it in 10
years it's probably terrible but i
remember that being like
a kind of scary movies and the and the
other obviously the epic movies and
their ilk but not another teen movie i
remember really really enjoying uh more
so than any of the others just that song
about uh true love's what i want the
most that just jerked off in your french
toast
will come unbidden into my head to this
very
um yeah
all right uh let's keep going with that
bro ryder a little dash will do you
donald belson
king of the beverly hill brother from
another mother so it's technically fine
relax
kaibo
guys and doll face
inconceivably sexy
the american education system the only
relatable character for anyone over 25.
uh something that's interesting like
that kind of uh is hanging over the film
i think for me is like what is her dad
doing
like what is love
one thing that's always been really
interesting to me and they don't dive
into it and it's probably not my place
to say it but i just love that like
cher is so obviously jewish and like the
phenomena
right the last name
yeah and they never get into it and i
kind of find that in january that might
have been in a draft and then when they
cast alicia silverstone they're like
let's
yeah i don't know i don't know i don't
know if this still works
yeah i just think that like because josh
is studying environmental law so
he's probably not on the side of the
of the national park system
in whatever case he's working on he's
probably holding that whole thing like
obviously when you're writing the script
there needs to be a reason that josh is
ostensibly coming around other than just
to see share because you don't want to
at the beginning they're not hanging out
you know it has to be like they discover
they enjoy hanging out but it feels very
flimsy like i get that you don't want to
spend that much time and you just want
to have him around the house but he's
helping out with some research like like
dana dye is this big beverly hills
lawyer doesn't have a staff in his
office that they could be doing this
research he's bringing it home and
having people in his house just sitting
around at his dining room table what is
all of this research how is why is paul
rudd of all people helping him out like
maybe it's a very thin
yeah as a former paralegal that part
bugs me so much now
i'm not going to my boss's house that's
right the whole thing is just and if i
am i'm not wearing a suit
what if he had a crush on their ex-step
kid
like half the time they're working at
his house doing his law work he's not
even there like wait is he at the office
and people are doing the legal work in
his house well like it doesn't make any
sense
oh man damn it and that's why i don't
like clueless
i'm kidding keep playing and cher
playing with her hair
marvel's as if
thank you very much
okay how often do kids break out into
applause for each other in class was
that a thing it was never a thing
and everybody clapped and everyone
stories about all the times i took down
my teacher with facts and logic and
everybody crap
this all happened at a downtown hipster
coffee shop
all right thank you thank you all
yes sadly
that's that's a crappy reference that we
all get
thanks for watching everyone um please
like and subscribe and hit the bell so
you don't miss another video that we
make here on phantom entertainment i'm
sure there's some good stuff coming up
there always is um but i know what's
good and what's coming up is the
outtakes uh let's watch the deleted
scenes from clueless
but even if they aren't related josh is
still a college guy dating a 16 year old
girl let's just say a law student should
know better
starring
they've been confused the blonde leading
the blonde
sharing means caring loquacious d
i'm a stupid man
bald ambition
no i am not on scrubs scrubs is a show
that's not on in the 90s
watching
paul in the family
franklin and trashed
breaking the law
swing a ding ding kid stereotypical
share fan
the tragically hipster
mall bratz
it's a wonderful life
praying girls
emma let you finish but clueless is the
best adaptation of all time
a movie made for teens that also
satirizes them but not too hard or their
feelings might get hurt it's basically
starship troopers but without the
fascism and space bugs or beams
well john improv that one
we uh i love the the starship troopers
comparison i guess that's why i like
both of these movies that just make fun
of but also show off uh funny
good-looking teenagers
yeah i mean i think that verhoeven in a
weird way is doing the same the same
balance where it's like you do kind of
have to invest in this scenario to care
about the film but also obviously it's
like a big goof and we're making fun of
these stupid kids and like that's not
that's not always as easy to do as they
make it look yep yep god i love paul
bearhoven
all right on to the questions um
evan jay pretzel ass uh nice moment i
want to do can we please take time
during the question period to wish
danielle late happy birthday
happy birthday danielle happy birthday
thank you
there was one guy that used to keep
track of the birthdays and he's gone so
yeah damn it sorry happy belated
birthday daniel something's in the mail
it's fine we don't need cookies we're
not in the office anymore
we had we had so many cookies when we
were in that office together that i
think we're dead for like 40 years yeah
i'm cooked we've conserved four years
worth of cookies yeah
well happy birthday and i'm sure
everyone in the chat is sounding off as
well um jeffrey elverton s uh which
movie character most closely resembles
your actual high school self
oh well oh
wow like from clueless or just any movie
character
uh who was that and davison confused um
that redhead nerd girl who's trying very
hard to keep up with everyone
uh
i don't remember that character's name
but i'm picturing her right now yeah the
one she ends up with adam goldberg the
whole time yeah yeah
yeah
um that is definitely my like i was the
nerd who tried to be cool um
uh just uh did too many drugs and then
discovered they just helped my 80d uh
that was the person i was
i'm i'm drawing a blank i don't know
i'm gonna go with the
enid from ghost world thor birch i
always i found that movie that movie
came out after i was no longer in high
school but i immediately found it very
relatable i had that same like that kind
of
i don't know i guess i got a mixture of
feeling kind of alienated and isolated
but also kind of thinking that you're a
little bit better and smarter than
everyone and that's the explanation why
and so then looking back you're like
well that's why no one wanted to hang
out with you uh so yeah i feel like
steve buscemi did
right yeah so i found that i found that
movie very relatable when it came out
and that's the first one that popped
into my head yeah
i always felt i just found both of the
peach the most
spoke to me in different ways from pete
and pete so uh the adventures up yeah
yeah so a merger a merger of two peats
kind of described but if not my
personality then my goals uh throughout
high school and beyond and you were
friends with the strongest man in the
world so that makes sense you were also
around
awesome um let's see here
i mean i feel like if we could use tv i
would also say marty sherman the
critic's son from the animated series
just a physical double for me in high
school yeah
yeah um let's see uh someone asked what
happened to my old prop guitar how dare
you i i played a lot of bass not guitar
thanks and it's a
it's just it's uh it's off camera relax
um and then uh clues became a terrible
tv show has any movie ever successfully
jumped to the small screen and i mean
let's let's say besides fargo because i
think fargo is going to be the top like
i take umbrage clueless tv was a great
tv show oh okay i take total umbridge i
really love it
i've seen every episode
it is genuinely really good um and it
winds up redeeming some of the
characters and it's all on youtube uh so
go check it out how rip i would say uh
maybe maybe that lasted the the entire
run but there have been some good like
first seasons of a show like westworld
season one i thought was really good
bates motel season one was really good
uh also fox did a two season exorcist tv
show with uh john cena and jim davis and
a few other good people were in that and
that was actually surprisingly good
pretty pretty recently
nice all right let's wrap up with this
one um aditya agarwal asks if clueless
is the most 90s movie i think it's
hackers but fine um what is the what is
the most 2010s movie
the 2010 so that would be 2000 to 2010
or
or 2010 to
i think our the the decade we just we
just wrapped up the one we just would
assume yeah those would be the 2010s
like the the decade the decade that just
passed
gosh um yeah
that's a really good question yeah
i was going to say oh no
doesn't it have to be like
like
captain marvel or something like is
doesn't that define that it certainly
defines the era in film more than
anything else we'll look back like oh
yeah that was like superhero saturation
like uh self-aware
mcu movie stuff but yeah i mean i'm i'm
tempted to almost be right like the meg
or something right like a a
chinese-american large cast
co-production with effects and
you know like like that that to me feels
like the prototypical kind of movie that
we make now yeah yeah everything i'm
thinking of is like that when the air
when the 2000s merged into the 2010s
those are all of the kind of movies that
i'm thinking of right because i think
they really defined like
this is the last time we're doing this
like the hangover movies and stuff like
that where it's like oh this is the last
time we're gonna do this movie yeah
i mean there's something to be said for
like
like if you want to
look at a moment that like frozen in
time like aesthetic wise that will
probably never happen again is something
like spring breakers where it's like oh
that's what a certain part of like youth
culture in the 2010s
that was early 20s i feel like that
might be 2010 then yeah because i was
also thinking of that error like i'd be
like like fast five like the fast and
furious is five through seven
those are also like
landmark of this past decade like this
is what we were into
everything is ridiculously huge the
physical logic of the world is out the
window everything's massively franchised
and it's and it's also furious 7
especially captures that like extreme
pathos and emotion intermixed with just
the dumbest nonsense you've ever seen
like right next to each other yeah which
i think is kind of what we that's what
we do now yep yep
well that's cinema once again uh thank
you
bond you know going to me that's it
thanks everybody for watching uh we will
be back next week for surprise surprise
another uh franchise film that didn't
really work out so good
that's i like clueless a lot better than
next week's pick let me know but i think
we're rolling them deuces yeah well i
think it's got it's um it's redeeming
qualities but we'll talk about that next
week uh here on us trailer commenters
see you then bye-bye
this episode was brought to you by hulu
[Music]
you